shut up she's trying to study in
left4dead news oh that game is pretty
fun by the way very fun the sequel was
great
oh I didn't play the sequel submitted by
JK fan for life naive yeah a man tried
to kill his ex-wife but major fail why
do you want to kill someone I know that
feeling
it was passion I know that feeling to
kill you know that feeling to kill like
what like you want to end their life
right you thought that about me no you
thought about ending my life I didn't
say anything yes your lies your yet
shifty a sizable asian boy I think we
can all empathize with the feeling of
failure and how bad it feels mm-hmm yes
that's the real story it's all I can say
you tried his best hole and it didn't
reach his goal you always got a try
right when you fail get up dude I can
try your ass I'll try harder so what
happened to so this is a story about a
woman and her abusive husband I don't
like it this all takes place in
Wisconsin so David is the husband and
Terry is the wife all right so David was
really abusive in the relationship he
would yell at Terry constantly for
things like leaving the if the curtains
were out of place or if she didn't fold
the towels what a stickler so then there
was this one night where they had an
argument over spaghetti that she was
cooking dinner she let spaghetti out and
he was telling her that she needs to put
the spaghetti get back before I got bad
and then it just led to like a really
bad argument to the point where she ran
down to the basement to get away from
him and that was the only place that she
had to go cuz because of all the doors
being locked and he only had the keys so
then she says that she'd just found
herself there she told herself like I'm
30 years old sitting in a box in my
basement hiding from my husband what the
hell am i doing so at that point that
was like the catalyst that drove her to
go get divorced good girl
the day of the divorce in court David
was
flying the hands up telling her and a
really threatening way like you're going
to regret this
so then three years later Terry ended up
remarrying
to this man named Nick as she was
pregnant and at this point David started
to fight for custody for the two
daughters and the court granted him
joint custody because they were
impressed that a father actually wanted
to spend time with his kids despite the
fact that he beat her what was just so
weird and it's like recorded like she
reported it yeah Nicole Simpson showed
dude yeah
what [ __ ] 11 incident photos and
everything and it's just yeah so then he
was granted joint custody and then so
every time David and Terry had to
interact with the drop-off and the
pickup of the daughters he would
verbally and physically assault her
which I'm thinking like what what about
the boy the husband I know right I mean
once a girl remarries he's like the new
security guard yeah it's his duty to
kick his ass yeah so I but maybe he was
scared yeah that's really scared I could
see that that happening yeah I be scared
cuz fear could be immobilizing you could
just freeze yeah go go go pick up the
kids yourself I'm staying home yeah I'm
a little scared of this guy frankly huh
your mind going alone hey Mel watch TV
get the couches warm they're making
jokes
so then Terry just kept insisting that
for them they're just exchanged with
kids in public places she ended up
calling the police twice and filed a
restraining order and when she filed
this restraining order it barred David
from possessing any weapons but Terry
already knew that he had a gun in the
house but the cops couldn't confiscate
that gun without a search warrant so he
still ended up keeping the gun she also
was saying how he held onto a lot of
their wedding items and after the
divorce he still lived in that same
house and so he would be showing their
daughters like a wedding dress photos
video footage of the wedding and he
would do this to these daughters as
proof that mommy doesn't keep her
promises mama nephew
working that sucks he's manipulating the
children's so the day of the attempted
murder David had asked Terry to pick up
their daughters from his house and so
Terry agreed she should've remarried
with a jujitsu master yeah yeah dude
just hang out at dojos and just try to
seduce one yeah girls if you're an
abusive relationship you need to get
with the new guy that could beat up the
old guy I feel it won't beat you up they
go the opposite way because they were
with someone so aggressive yeah so they
like go with a beta male no you got
something from more aggressive start
going on all the us the Justice
aggressive guys the real aggressive guys
that are aggressive toward other guys
are not women yeah this guy's like her
new guys it's like it's like oh [ __ ]
your ex-husbands going over it's like
hold on let me paint in something really
aggressive say wow she shouldn't go with
an MMA fighter he's in what if she gets
tough it's [ __ ] more machine number 2
yeah that's what I'm saying that's why
most but that's one of a million though
- yeah it's like a more soft gentle male
after or a girl
maybe they try girls for a little bit
because they get like so traumatized but
Chris has been I'll get what the
doctrine or something that comes with
like a beastly animal yeah he's a jeez a
trainer of a beastly thing exactly how
did he try to kill her okay so the day
of the attempted murder that's when she
told he told her like Cohen pick up our
daughters from my house she went there
when he opened the door he was
uncharacteristically calm which really
weirded out Terry I just busted nuts dis
jacked off news you just bought somebody
with the daughters in the room so David
told Terry that their daughters are
playing hide and seek and that they want
their mom to go find them no Terry come
on her gut said no but she didn't want
to disappoint her daughters oh we ended
up going in the house looking for them
sister where is her husband throughout
all this stuff exactly
he was painting aggressively in the
Attic he's like I'm gonna give him a
[ __ ] finger painting for me matter
birthday I'm gonna do I'm gonna give him
some space
second thing I'm gonna do
is given this painting one address so
three hours later I kind of seek for
dreamers so long game
Nick ended up calling the police because
I was already way too long because she
should've returned already with the
girls so then Nick gave the dispatchers
David's address and the dispatchers had
recognized it because they said earlier
there was a breathless woman that had
called my name and gave them the same
address why did they go there
so then deputies got there but the house
is empty so then they started asking
neighbors if they saw anything and the
neighbors said that they saw David
towing Terry's car earlier that morning
so then that was the second 911 call and
this time it was Terry as she was able
to stay conscious long enough to give
authorities some really important
information which was her name and her
ex-husband was trying to kill her and
that she was in the back of his green
pickup truck and so detectives returned
to David's home and found black
sweatpants that Nick said that Terry was
wearing they also found a really large
blood stain on the carpet and an empty
handgun case and so they immediately
assumed that Terry had been badly
insulted obviously by David and the fact
that David's arm so then nearly a
hundred officers set out to go follow
any leads that they could for like 26
hours they were looking and so police
waited for David's who arrived to work
which by the way he's an air traffic
controller and so was [ __ ] contrives
he got to what my brothers are
controlled you got some [ __ ] the same
watch I was a DC but you'll get some
[ __ ] I heard that that's a really
stressful job like one of the most
stressful jobs in the world
that's true my brother really is a TC
and he says it's yeah it's trust me he
gives the best light shows that race do
ya prio for sure yeah yeah so then when
David got to work there was no Terry no
daughters and so officers told him that
his ex-wife has had been missing and if
he could just go down to the police
station for some questioning and say
that he can help him with anything
the sheriff was just saying like I was
begging him talking to him with
tremendous amount
but like trying to get something out of
him because they knew like berating me
like yeah is doing something or hiding
something they just should have tortured
him yeah so then finally is when after
all that time is when they dropped the
bomb saying that they found the evidence
in his home and so that's when he
started getting really nervous and then
he started getting like really really
emotional and he ended up saying that
Terry had attacked him and that he
responded in self-defense but the rest
was a blur oh my god and so they're the
authorities already had enough evidence
to detain him and so he confiscated his
personal belongings and in his wallet
they saw a card for a storage facility
near a town where David had property so
then they ended up calling the storage
facility and they said that yes he does
own that storage facility and he had
visited that morning so the cops got to
the storage facility they just saw a
baseball bat that had like crusted all
my blood on it and like this garbage
container like a trash container and so
they opened it and they found Terry
there oh my god you said that her body
temperature was 86 degrees Fahrenheit
that they was freezing they were saying
that she was literally like one hour
away from dying like she's bleeding to
death or something no because it was so
cold and then also because she had
suffered like trauma like her from from
being hit so she was shot or hit with
the baseball bat baseball bat so where
did the empty gun case income he was
threatening her with it but he didn't
actually shoot her and so they're saying
like her feet were so black that it
looked like she was wearing socks
oh she was bitten and like her eyes were
swollen shut she was in the fetal
position could you kill the mother of
your children so crazy
so they're saying that she ended up
spending about seven weeks in the
hospital or trying to recuperate and she
underwent ten different operations and
she also lost the baby
yeah why did she lose her feet no but
they did say that she was a
wheelchair-bound for several more weeks
after her recovery oh this sucks so what
happened to him three years so yeah the
service that David end up game the
painting the aggressive painting yeah
because he Boyd mailed it to him wait
the [ __ ] time I really hope he
delivered the painting he didn't want to
confront with the painting he mailed it
to him so we'll find out it was so quick
for the detectives til I find that card
and go right away yeah David was
sentenced to 35 years in prison for a
first-degree intentional homicide 35
years that's it there's life and so how
does he get 35 years and then some cats
get like 237 years and he planted all
that with the hide-and-seek yeah so it
was cleared clear that's [ __ ] and
then he lied about the attack obviously
you know they gave him like six hours to
tell truth but luckily he didn't check
Terry to see if she had a cell phone set
so she was able to call the cops when
she was in the truck but they're saying
that David had brutally assaulted Terry
with the baseball bat while their
daughters were locked in the back
bedroom of the home and so they're
saying that the girls started crying
because they were so hungry and they
were no longer distracted by the movie
that he had played for them don't put
frozen so many times but she was hearing
your girls cry and like you're getting
beat I'm so happy she's alive me too
yeah me too
that would have sucked that she died
terry has been helping draft laws to
protect domestic violence victims yes
yeah training order if they say like
they oh you can't have weapons but then
they can't actually enforce that law
exactly like I was thinking like that
was more enforced if you have a
restraining order you can't own a weapon
right that makes sense yeah if they have
priors of domestic violence and all that
like we need to find a better way to
regulate watch it and did Terry
break up with Nick no so they're still
married and they have a nine-year-old
son David nick is still painting yeah
Terry on her second wedding day with her
two daughters that sucks dad to go
through that yeah Wow can we find out
what prison this guy's in and we can
just all send a mail of like hey you
suck
oil paintings yeah dinners dunno just
sent him like a [ __ ] just like
handwritten letters I'm gonna give him
hate mail of like drawings that'll show
him he'll oh he'll open it up and be
like Oh more like a scary picture dude I
just draw a [ __ ] scary like a ghost
he's like oh look yeah
damn I hate getting a hate letter time
in prison I mean the best revenge is
taking pictures of Terry in really happy
situations yeah spawn dude she she's
sending pictures like her at TGI Fridays
with mid jula she's like yeah that's
right I'm living the [ __ ] life and
with a gift card you know I'm not [ __ ]
Sultan how's it going guys don't forget
to like the video because if you don't I
will break your [ __ ] legs thank you
so much for the last video don't forget
to click right here or I'll break your
[ __ ] arms click right here guys
[Music]